so I've really been educating people
about the importance of zinc on quite a
few videos but the problem is there is a
point where you can have too much so
this video is on the toxic effect of
zinc if you're trying to support your
immune system zinc is crucial but the
question is how much are you taking now
if you take large amounts over a short
period of time there's not going to be
an issue but I'm talking about if you're
taking large amounts over many many
months you could create a copper
deficiency so I just want to talk about
the symptoms of a copper deficiency
nausea vomiting pain diarrhea high LDL
low HDL swayback but you're probably not
going to get a swayback this usually
happens before you're born but that's
just one of the symptoms anemia pale
decreased appetite you're irritable the
Teague you can also have a problem with
building collagen because you need
copper to build collagen zinc and copper
work together too much zinc you deplete
copper so I always recommend when you're
taking zinc take copper with it as well
as all the trace minerals together and
that way you never have to worry about
it and let me just explain what I mean
by a extremely high amount of zinc so
let's say you're taking 300 milligrams
for several weeks that can be too much
typically if you have some lung problem
like pneumonia or some type of lower
respiratory issue you'd want to take 225
milligrams
okay but I also recommend take the
copper with it take the trace minerals
with it just to make sure you don't
create another problem and a lot of
people consume a lot more than that but
the threshold seems to be like a hundred
milligrams if you stay below that you
can take that for a good period of time
without having a problem but if they
just start going over a hundred you
start creating problems with copper it's
not just taking zinc over a period of
time it's the amount of zinc that you're
taking and then you have the time
variable as well and on the flip side
too
it's out this conversation about zinc
being toxic in large amounts most people
are deficient in zinc and our bodies do
not retain zinc for any period of time
so we're constantly losing zinc and we
need it so if you're not consuming foods
that have zinc chances are you'll
probably be deficient and there's a
whole series of symptoms with that you
want to think about just the right
amount you want to make sure you have
the foods with enough zinc but if you're
just taking with copper and all the
trace minerals you're gonna be totally
fine and as far as the video on zinc
deficiency I put that link down below
check it out so I just spent the last
two months creating this amazing course
called how to bulletproof your immune
system and there's 21 different lessons
and I want to give you this course for
free and the problem I have with giving
it free is sometimes people don't value
it as much but I want to get it out
there so I'm just gonna give it to you
free and I want to let you know that
it's extremely extremely valuable right
now we're in a situation of uncertainty
they're talking about a second wave and
other people are waiting for this
miracle vaccine that maybe say who knows
it's all unknown so what is the big
elephant in the room no one is talking
about the immune system they're not
emphasizing the most important thing
that you can do to bulletproof yourself
against viruses and bacteria but this
course is going to lay out things in 21
different lessons I'm gonna teach you
very simply what your immune system is
and exactly what you can do to
strengthen it using natural things there
are three requirements number one I want
you to share it very very widely can you
imagine if thousands of people had this
information to protect themselves but
not only that getting rid of the fear
factor which I believe is worse than the
virus I mean when you think about it
it's very similar to someone being
bullied in school as soon as they learn
self-defense they're gonna be less
adversely affected by these bullies so
why not give you the information on your
immune system so you know what to do
detect yourself you see a lot of people
that are scared I see them on exercise
like in in the park they're wearing a
mask while they're exercising or walking
by themselves or in a car they're
wearing a mask and a shield so please
share this course with everyone you know
if you want to help someone this is the
best way to help them to give them the
knowledge of how to strengthen your
immune system we want this to go viral
in a healthy way all right number two be
active on your course and actually
complete the course okay take your time
really learn the information there's
questions that you're gonna have to
answer but stick with it and number
three
send me your success when you complete
the course and sometimes when I talk to
people they end the conversation with be
safe and I thought to myself what does
that mean be safe
well wear the mask and also avoid
getting too close to people right well
that's cool but what about strengthening
the immune system that way you could be
not just safe but you could be very very
smart because the missing link is a
strong immune system that gives you the
ultimate protection I really believe
that the best thing that we can do both
you and I to help people is to spread
this out and get everyone to know this
information and here's what I came up
with for the top three people that share
this course with the most people I'm
gonna give them a one-hour one-on-one
video consult with dr. Burke myself and
we can talk about anything or your
health or whatever and then for the top
100 people that share this course I'm
gonna give this group video accidents to
a very special webinar that's going to
be live on a topic that I can't
necessarily do in a YouTube video
because it'll be taken down but just
realize it's going to be some very
powerful information that you're going
to learn that's gonna really help you
and people around you sorry to give you
that mystery but unfortunately social
media is filtering out certain topics
right now and the top 100 will also get
access to my virtual
Kito summit at the end of august last
point to get access to this information
you have to have messenger now some of
you don't use messenger and
unfortunately everything is set up a
messenger so I would recommend signing
up a messenger and if you don't want to
continue use it after the course just
opt-out I think you're really going to
enjoy this course I put a lot of time
into it the information is down below
and spread the word